Here's the question sheet and Google the
answer.
Imagine that you have to buy a house.
Where would be cheaper?
Barcelona or Miami if you need a clear.
Let me tell you that both cities have
more or less the same population.
If we consider the metropolitan area,
both cities have beaches and to very
touristy.
In addition,
the average salary in Miami is almost
twice the one in Barcelona and the
unemployment rate is much,
much lower.
Having said all of that many,
many things that my logic Barcelona
would be cheaper than Miami.
Well,
if you're thinking that you're actually
wrong,
heightens in Miami are 15 percent
cheaper than those in Barcelona.
If you were buying a house in Spain is
truly an impossible mission,
but I know what you may be thinking
right now.
Houses.
Well,
they're expensive everywhere,
right?
Well,
yeah,
you are actually right.
House prices are rising in almost every
country and this is especially
surprising if we consider that the trend
is quite the opposite for other good.
We've said it already on this channel
like a thousand times.
Humanity is just doing better.
We've practically eradicated
malnutrition old around the world.
Our standard of living is much higher
than that of our grandparents and this
is pretty much do among other things to
the fact that the products we consume,
they're getting cheaper.
For instance,
just 30 years ago,
our parents would have to save an
average month salary to fly from London
to Berlin.
Nowadays,
that's just history.
That's housing is the only elements that
hasn't become more accessible.
Indeed.
It's becoming almost prohibitively
expensive in many parts of the world.
In this video,
we're going to focus on Spain,
but many of the things we're going to
review because happen in almost any
country because the question that we're
asking ourselves today is why is it so
damn expensive to buy a house and can we
do anything to solve this?
Well,
we are going to answer these questions
today,
but first let's dive into the history
law of the land.
Once the first and most important thing
we need to build a house,
well,
that would of course be the lambs that
were going to build it on rice.
Well,
in that aspect,
Spain has the perfect geography.
We're talking about a huge,
relatively flat country with many
unpopulated areas.
Are the countries,
for example,
the Netherlands,
do you have the very real problem that
they high population density?
However,
Spain has plenty of space for all of its
inhabitants.
No.
Having a
piece of land doesn't necessarily mean
we can use it to build houses.
For example,
in 2011 40 percent of the land in the
capital,
Madrid was considered not urbanized.
This means that the city council limits
construction in these territories.
In other cities such as Malaga,
this percentage even rises to more than
percent.
You might be wondering,
well,
why all of a sudden many lands where you
can't build up the onset of this lies in
municipal services.
You see when you build in a residential
area,
you need sewers,
electricity,
new bus lines,
and of course things like garbage
collection and say,
well,
who's responsible for all of these
costs?
The city councils,
that is every.
Okay.
If a construction company proposes a
housing development on the outskirts of
Madrid,
it doesn't manage to sell them all.
Every local will have to pay for a ghost
areas.
Urban services
due to all of this town councils have
decided to control every single detail
of where and how that municipality you
can extend in Spain.
This is done through a legal instruments
known as the urban ordination plans.
These are maps that every city will
publishes every 10 years specifying the
areas in which someone can build,
because hold on a second,
maybe you're Spanish and you're watching
this video from Spain.
Now I know what you might be thinking.
Isn't land supposed to be liberalized in
Spain in 1997,
Jose,
Maria,
as Sonos governments put out a law
that's involved in theory land
liberalization.
This means that in theory all of the
countries lands became developable.
That is essentially it is suitable for
construction.
Suddenly every Spanish city group and
lots of residential areas emerged.
This was the beginning of the housing
bubble butts.
As we've mentioned many times the devil
in the details take.
Now,
we said that the urban ordination plans
determine the areas one can build on,
but that's not the entire picture hat.
It also sets the conditions for
building.
Okay,
imagine we're requesting a permit from
the Barcelona City Council to build a
block of flats on a plot that we own.
Well,
the city council will say absolutely no
problem,
but you can only build 20 homes or 15 or
maybe even just
10.
They need to see the problem.
Even if construction is allowed,
housing supply is still highly
restricted and by the way,
this also explains many of Spain's
corruption cases.
Most of the scandals that have been
discovered in recent years were revealed
because developer,
it was bing a town planning a council so
that instead of getting a permit for 10
houses,
they'd get one for twice as many.
In other words,
the construction sector has a larger and
more perverse incentive to essentially
invest in bribes than any other sex at
like for example,
incurred in the 20th century.
Can you guess the least productive
sector of the economy,
as you might imagine it is indeed
construction.
We're talking about a world where it's
all just.
You find a project actually being built
by its due date,
and this isn't just limited to Spain.
They give you an idea.
The new apple offices in Silicon Valley,
they were completed two years later than
expected and has an extra cost of
$2,000,000,000 and the same happens with
almost every house built,
right?
One survey of British architects found
that 60 percent of their buildings were
late
and so well.
Now you might be wondering,
well pointed these things out,
but as whole the answer essentially lies
in a lack of innovation.
Of course,
houses today a much more modern.
They have better insulation that a
heating systems,
but the way in which they're built is
pretty much the same as it was 50 years
ago.
Any economic sector,
it's just much more advanced.
For example,
a car factory 60 years ago,
it looks nothing like a car factory
today.
Most of the jobs,
our grandparents health have simply been
replaced by computer programs,
machines and robots.
What's the results of this?
Well,
nowadays a call has many more features
and is cheaper to make than it was 60
years ago.
Thanks to that.
Now almost every family can afford one
or even two.
However,
if we saw a construction project from
the 19 sixties with barely notice any
difference with one done today at all,
same builders,
same grains,
I mean construction companies have
barely invested at all in innovation and
it's understandable.
If we take,
they're extremely low profit margins
into accounts.
You
heard that,
right?
Housing developer can expect a profit
margin of two to five percent.
Of course,
if we're talking about millions of
euros,
two percent is more than enough to make
the company's owner rich.
You gotta hit that,
Ya know,
barely allows them to reinvest in other
things such as research and development.
And if this weren't enough,
there are very few incentives to replace
workers in machines
and if this was not enough,
there are very few incentives to replace
workers with machines here.
Unlike other economic sectors,
working in construction requires initial
training as well.
This leads to a greater concentration of
low skills.
We can summarize everything like this.
There's a restricted land supply which
makes property prices rise,
and then there's a long and expensive
and unpredictable construction process.
Now,
what's the result of all of this?
Both homes in Spain have become
prohibitively expensive.
However,
almost 80 percent of Spaniards,
they've managed to own their own home.
So the question is now,
well,
how is this possible?
Well,
let's dive into that money for everyone.
That's a basic principle in economics.
Things all worth what someone is willing
to pay for them.
For example,
if a foreign flat in a normal
neighborhood of Madrid is worth more
than 300,000 years,
it's because someone can afford to pay
more than 300,000 euros.
That how can there be so many people who
can pay so much?
I mean,
isn't Spain's supposed to be in a
financial crisis?
Didn't we say that the average salary in
Spain is less than 2000 euros a month?
Okay,
well,
dear viewer,
the answer lies of course in the banks,
300,000 euros is a true fortune for
someone earning an average salary.
Bart,
if one pays all that money in
comfortable installments over many,
many years,
it'd be a bit easier.
And so how many years do you think we're
talking about here?
Ten years.
Twenty years?
Well,
the truth is that we're talking about a
lot,
lot longer,
40 year mortgages in exclusive and
conditional product for young people.
Forty years is an incredible amounts of
time and it's really not uncommon in
Spain to find people.
You have these 40 year mortgages and
some may say to all of this,
what's really the sense in that?
Imagine you're a bank and you grounds a
couple,
a 40 year loan,
a thousand different things can happen
in four decades,
which means they might not be able to
return the money.
So where's the business for the bank
here?
How can the bank risk so much when
grunting alone?
Oh,
well,
the answer to that is in the central
thank you.
Be to keep printing billions of euros to
prop up the eurozone until 2019.
You really did hear that Rice.
Nowadays,
Europe is producing more money
than ever.
However,
Europe does have a relatively low
inflation.
Great.
In another visual politic video,
we did explain that when central banks
print bills prices,
they tend to go up.
However,
in Europe the opposite happens so well,
why is this?
Well,
that's because all of that newly printed
money that goes directly to the banks
and the banks he was at for.
Well,
of course that was the loan.
That explains why even with relatively
low salaries,
most Spaniards are willing to pay real
fortunes to own a house and what's worse
prices continue to rise unabated.
It will always be someone willing to
originate or take out a 40 year
mortgage.
In other words,
all the factors point to the fact that
this in the long term housing will
become more and more expensive and that
explains things like this.
Housing profitability
rises as an investment.
This means that along with the people
who buy an apartment to live in is there
are people who buy them as an
investments and other words central
banks inflate to hens.
Municipalities restrict supply
conclusion of all of this.
Houses are becoming more expensive every
single day and at this point I just want
to take the time to thank Miguel and
health on seconds,
architectural studies for helping us
understand all the details of the world
of construction in and planning in
Spain.
Gal and how Fonseca is one of the
greatest experts of sustainable
architecture in Spain.
You can find more details about him in
the video description below
and well now it's time to turn to you.
How do you think this problem should be
solved?
Do you think we should restrict bank
mortgages?
What about released the land in order to
be able to build more?
What kind of policies do you think would
solve this problem?
Well,
please leave your answers in the
comments below and as always,
let me thank the reconsider media
podcasts they provided the vocals in
this episode that are not mine.
Click that like button below and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday,
and as always,
thank you for watching and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
more mine,
lovely voice,
don't forget to check out the reconsider
podcast@reconsidermedia.com.
We consider as a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your reviews by
providing context,
but we don't do the thinking.